[Music]
foreign
a ton of breaking news this Monday uh
all right tonight economic Insanity
border chaos Democrats in disarray will
bring you the very latest from the Bob
Menendez bribery charges and of course
the Joe Biden issue we'll get to in a
second also today huge news uh
game-changing updates as it relates to
the Biden bribery and money laundering
Scandal allegations and Biden's
weaponized doj new evidence coming out
today we'll break that news and then
later it is very important in terms of
an election year especially for the
Commonwealth of Virginia now Virginia
governor Glenn yunkel will join us with
the details straight ahead and are the
are Virginia legislative changes in the
near future what would it mean what
would it tell us maybe about 2024 also
tonight a big announcement the red State
versus Blue State debate hosted by Yours
Truly between Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis governor of California Gavin
Newsom is now officially on we've got
details at the end of the show but first
bad news for your President Joe Biden he
is now polling worse than ever losing to
Donald Trump by a whopping double digits
Biden is now down 10 points in a brand
new ABC News Washington Post poll and as
much as Democrats and the media mob
would like to pretend that it's just an
outlier well the last eight polls showed
Donald Trump of the lead or at least
tied with Biden in a hypothetical
match-up in multiple polls Biden's
approval is at an all-time low even
Democrats are deeply unhappy with the 80
year old who now occupies the White
House take a look
there's clearly a lack of enthusiasm
about the president himself because we
asked primary voters on the Democratic
side do you want options next year
besides Biden 59 said yes they do this
is not a normal number for an incumbent
we ask the same question a year before
Donald Trump sought re-election of
Republicans only 37 percent wanted more
choices than that's a very high number
that's demos DNC now when you lose let's
see uh David Ignatius Washington Post
Maureen Dowd New York Times liberal Joe
you lose uh let's see van Jones James
Carville David Axelrod
um you're in trouble Biden support now
collapsing among several key
demographics that includes young voters
Hispanic Americans African-Americans hmm
I wonder why take a look two of the
great artists of our time representing
the groundbreaking Legacy of hip-hop in
America
llj Cool J
by the way that boy's got he got man's
got biceps bigger than my thighs
llj cool and refers to him as boy okay
earlier in the week Biden confused the
Congressional Hispanic caucus with the
Congressional Black Caucus during a
speech honoring the Hispanic caucus now
before that he told the exact same story
twice in a mere matter of minutes during
a fundraiser what is that indication of
let's think not difficult to figure out
he also got lost on stage during an
appearance with the Brazil president
forgetting to even shake the guy's hands
as walking off into nowhere land
obviously Biden's age is cognitive
decline is a top concern among Democrats
and frankly among every American we got
every week he brings more shame more
embarrassment to the Democratic party
and frankly to the country and as the
2024 election is now approaching uh new
political threat is on the horizon as
Newsweek put it quote Joe Biden's
nightmare election scenario might in
fact be coming true as Biden struggles
well possible third-party candidates
like Robert F Kennedy Jr Cornell West
they're gaining momentum according to a
recent poll a third of democratic voters
say they would vote for RFK Jr if he
runs as a third party candidate is also
concerned that quote No Labels party led
by West Virginia senator Joe manchin
they could also run Biden's chances or
ruinum in a sense for re-election
needless to say this you can feel an
overwhelming sense of anxiety and
frankly dread from the Democratic party
and don't expect Kamala to replace Joe
at the top of the ticket listen to James
Clyburn this weekend does this sound
like a real vote of confidence for her
let's turn to vice president Harris do
you see her as the future of the
Democratic Party
I see her as a part of that future
absolutely the future though is she the
future of the democratic party oh she
could very well be it's not a given you
don't automatically move up she'll have
to compete going forward with whoever it
may have dreams and aspirations and I
think she will acquit herself well
not a given huh okay this after the very
tepid support of Kamala Harris from well
yet another top Democrat take a look at
this is the best running mate for this
president
he thinks so and that's what matters and
by the way I think so she's very
politically astute I don't think people
give her enough credit do you think she
is the best running mate though she's
the vice president of the United States
so people say to me well why isn't she
doing this or that I said because she's
the vice president that's the job of
description
you don't do that much
he thinks so and vice presidents
basically do nothing so Democrats are
unhappy with both Biden and Harris now
there are very real fears that they will
lose in 2024 and they're Justified now
literally the country's an entire mess
Biden's act frankly is beyond you know
anything we can comprehend ever
happening and you know loving middle
class family man Joe has simply
collapsed the image has been shattered
the illusion has been shattered now
Americans see Biden for who he really is
a morally corrupt liar willing to even
disown his own four-year-old
granddaughter for political gain
allegedly used his struggling son as a
Bag Man to collect you know tens of
millions of dollars for the family
business by the way coming up tonight
too Miranda Devine will join us with a
new report on how Biden's weaponized doj
helps Shield the president uh and his
son from legal scrutiny while
aggressively pursuing legal action at
against Biden's Chief political rival
that would be Donald Trump hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else